hey guys now i made a lot of videos
about modeling how to become a model
how much money models really make posing
tips for men and women
and i also showed you the modeling life
in all of my vlogs i
showed you some of the good things of
modeling and also some of the bad things
but now i need to be fully honest and i
need to talk about the
dark side of modeling
the things that you don't know and the
things that they don't want you to know
so in this video i'm going to talk about
five shocking
truths of the modeling world that they
don't want people to know
but you need to know and the world needs
to know as well
let's get to it
first you need to know about the
exploitation of
young girls it might be shocking to you
that most girls who start
modeling do it at a very young age and i
travel
to international countries especially to
asia
13 years old 14 15
and i say girls because they're not
women they're still kids
i've been doing international modeling
for over 13 years
and in most of these countries
especially when i go to asia
i see these young girls everywhere
i remember my first trip ever to asia
was to singapore i stayed in a model
apartment and i was invited to an event
that they were going to and when i went
to this private event
what i saw just shocking and it will
shock you
young 13 14 year old girls 15
with old perverted guys with a lot of
money
and drugs in the bathrooms it was it was
just something out of
a crazy movie but reality
now you got to remember most of these
countries especially from
eastern europe most of these girls they
can't speak english
so they go to a whole new country
without their parents
without any without anyone that really
looks after them of course sometimes
they do allow a parent to go with them
if they're very young like 13 and
sometimes a parent
will go with them but that's not
in all cases so they leave their country
they leave school
and they go to work in another country
to make money for their poor family back
at home
this is child labor and you know
they do underwear photo shoots and
videos
with other male models the worst place
where this all happens
is japan they love very
young girls but they do not like older
models so i haven't seen
one girl here that's over 24 25
ish most of them here are around 17 16
18 which is very very very young and you
know the worst part about this
is that their mother agency back at home
and their parents
allow this to happen but they don't
actually know what happens once they are
in the country
of all the clubs partying all perverted
people
with money this is sick and it is
child labor
the second thing you need to know about
is sexual favors
for work now of course this does not
happen everywhere and all the time
but it happens more than you think male
photographers designers
a lot of the professional people in the
industry clients
they make sexual advances to not just
female models
but to male models as well and they tell
them they will give them more
work if they do sexual favors for them
it's sick and over the last few years a
lot of models came out
and told the truth of sexual abuse and
rape like fashion designer anand john
who even appeared on america's next top
model according to the guardian he got
59
years in prison for raping many models
some were 14 years old at the time there
were
16 counts in california alone there's a
lot of cases about this and
if you're in modeling models talk you
talk and you hear rumors but then you
also hear
facts which is very scary over 50 models
came out and spoke
to the globe spotlight team and
identified some of these monsters at
least 25 photographers
agents stylists casting directors and
other professionals
big names like patrick the martialer
david bellmere
and craig kadel andre pasos and seth
sable now this is also mentioned by
model alliance who's one of the few
organizations
that are fighting for the rights of
models if you're a new model go check
them out there are instagram as well
now if you're a new model remember don't
ever go
to a photo shoot alone especially if the
photographer
contacted you on social media you don't
know
if you can trust them there are many
professional
predators out there that you cannot
trust and always remember if you are at
a photo shoot or a
modeling job you can always say no to
anything
if you feel uncomfortable don't feel
like you have to impress them to make a
name
for yourself if they say oh go topless
then don't feel like oh i have to do
this to make it
no if you don't feel comfortable doing
something
don't do it you have rights
i remember when i first started modeling
a while back
in cape town there was a very well-known
photographer
and he took photos of me a test shoot
meaning
i don't pay him money he doesn't pay me
any money we just use it for our
portfolios
so we're doing the photo shoot and it
became very weird
he asked me to take off all my clothes i
said no
and he said if you can't take off all
your clothes and shoot 100
nude you'll never be a great model they
try to manipulate
you while you're young i said no and i
left
what rubbish be very careful don't let
these people
deceive or manipulate you and give you
false promises
these people are wolves in sheep
clothing
be careful
models are not always paid the modeling
world
always sounds like glitz and glamour to
those who are outside
of the modeling industry most people
think that
the models out there are rich
while in fact most of them don't even
make anything
many of my modeling friends are still
waiting
for their money from an agency that they
worked for internationally
they were there for a two to three month
contract and they're still
waiting for the money after years
not just months years they just lie and
they say things like we're still waiting
for the money from the client or the
client never paid us so we can't pay you
crazy right
agencies take advantage of models
they charge them unfair fees let me
break this down for you
for any international modeling job
depending on the country that you go to
20 to 55 percent sometimes 60 percent
sometimes even more goes to that agency
in that country and then
10 goes to your mother agency back at
home
so you only get a little and then with
that money
after your contract two to three months
you need to pay all your
overcharged expenses with that money you
need to
pay for your accommodation com cards
transport
flight tickets agency administration and
so forth
so if you don't read your contract an
agency can take advantage of you
by charging you unfairly
they do it anyway even if you check the
contract let me take
accommodation for example they'll put
you and
three to ten other models in the same
apartment or same house
you get just a small bed and then they
charge everyone
a certain price which is actually more
than the price that they need to pay for
the house so they take the money that's
left
let me give an example let's say it cost
them five
thousand dollars right and their space
for six models and every model
needs to pay let's say a thousand five
hundred that gives the agency nine
thousand dollars
they only need to pay five thousand per
month and so they pocket 4
000 every month and then after that
there's still taxes to be paid there's
always
taxes and here's something else
sometimes before
the contract an agency will promise you
the stars and say come we've got a lot
of jobs just come over you'll work
because they
need a certain number of models right
because they need to present themselves
to the clients and also online so they
need to look
professional and always have enough
models so they promise certain models
the stars they come over
and then they don't get enough jobs of
course they have to go to castings first
so they go to castings
but the number of castings always differ
the agency might try the best
with castings but you can't control it
so you don't
get enough castings to book
jobs to have money and then after that
two or three months they did not get
enough
money so they end up owing the agency
money
now you need to know it was not always
like this
but right now there's a lot more models
there's a lot
more agencies and not enough work for
everyone
used to be a lot better way back when i
started
bullying it happens a lot from agencies
from clients and even sometimes from
other
models i can't even count the number of
times
that i saw especially young girls in
tears
because they were abused psychologically
because model agencies want them to be
perfect
you need to be more like that model you
need to be better at posing
you need to stop complaining about this
and do your job
do not talk back to the client do what
they tell you
even if it's weird things you need to be
skinnier
so go home you're not going to castings
for one week i've seen
agencies who don't even give their
models pocket money
weekly allowance if they are not
the correct size they do measurements
every week and then they're also
called names for wearing weird clothes i
remember even when i started i was
made a lot of fun off by an agency in
cape town for the clothes that i
had on because i felt comfortable in
these this is who i was at the time and
they just made fun of me
in front of everybody people in the
modeling industry can be very
rude and sarcastic especially if they
think
they are very important they're a very
important booker or photographer
or client they're very rude and they
don't care
and especially some of the big brands
those clients
very puffed up very arrogant
and they look down on you they look at
models just
as objects and not as human beings
they don't care about your feelings i
personally
strongly experienced this in italy
in milan some of those people worst kind
of people i've ever met
now this is not the same in every
country
so it will be different but i'm just
telling you the truth of what is out
there
you can find out probably in every type
of job that you get but
it happens a lot in the modeling
industry and then sometimes this kind of
pride
arrogant atmosphere gets into the models
as well
and it gets worse especially if they're
competing with each other if they've got
similar looks
and they're very rude to each other now
these things in the modeling industry
all of these things
that i shared is very important and it
should be talked about
and there's much more that we can
actually talk about like the fashion
industry
is the second largest polluter
in the world but i think that i've said
enough to make you aware of it
share this video with other people so
they will also
know and that something can be done
about all of this
i'll see you in the next video bye